hi everyone
um
and today I will be speaking about my
journey with my projects how I got
enrolled at the research panel so first
a brief introduction about myself I when
I joined fine I was an undergraduate
student in my first year and I was doing
integrated by medical Sciences now I'm
doing my Master's for integrated
biomedical Sciences which are the
specialization in neuroscience and my
interest rise in Neuroscience
neurogenetics cancer oncology concerned
with neuros and brain tumors so I had
always used a nostalgic idea about how
do I transform my wet lab ideas into a
dry lab
so then I came across time biotech and I
joined behind biotech as a Google family
services
so after joining as a growth Ambassador
I got to know the experts over there I
interacted with Elia Dr Mohit and the
mentors over there
and then I started talking with the
research fellows that were endorsedment
so my duties are generally comparison of
the social interactions interacting with
students and stuff like that so after
joining as a program working as like for
three months I then got to know about
the research partnership program that
was conducted Underpants about that so
then my mentors encouraged me to you
know join the research fellowship
program and I definitely learned from my
peers the outcome that they were having
so I then firstly developed the topic of
your interest that I wanted to work on
and as soon as I joined the research
fellowship program I was paired with her
mentor and that Mentor was with me from
the start till the end of my project
that was for the three month curation
program I was always interested in
Neuroscience so I took multiple
sclerosis and for your information I
never knew about informatics and I
didn't even
platform and trust me that's one of the
best platforms for youth to get you know
and inculcated with all these knowledge
because not only bioinformatics but also
all of its branches like genomics
epigenomic transcriptomics
everything was given and the coursework
by posters I don't really mean that they
give you the materials for reading
despite and after the materials they
also have interactive videos animated
videos they have the performance you
know a web browser that is the omics
logic code platform in which you can
enter your code and see if your results
are coming true or not and they also
have exercises and assignments and tests
for you to take on your own so that you
can assess yourself on the basis of
where you stand and how much knowledge
you have acquired so after doing this
coursework I work as a research fellow
to find it I said I didn't even know how
to find the data center what a data set
actually meant so the mentors over here
you're not in nurture you so nicely like
I was ashamed telling them that I don't
know data set and how to find them but
uh Dr Mohit Elia and Dr her who was my
mentor they all taught me how to find a
data center that's one-to-one
interaction meeting and every Friday I
guess when I was there every Friday
there was a recent fellowship meeting
once a weekly so you discuss your
progress and after discussing your
progress they tell you that okay you
have children this much now these are my
doubts so they help you solve the doubt
my hands on you know they share the
computer screen and on Hands-On
activities
and in the next meeting you saw that
progressed with them and one of the most
interesting thing of the research
scholarship program is they don't
dictate you that this is how you do your
project it is you who decided what part
you want to they only are there to guide
you that okay if you want to do this
this will tell this one if you want to
do this this is done they never tell you
that okay we have designed the project
for you unlike other institutes which
tell that okay we have to assign this
project for you and you can go and do it
and just submit it this is all you know
like a growth process or the process of
finding your own way your own hypothesis
so yeah that the intricacy and the
expositiveness of research fellowship
program over here so after you get
enrolled in the research fellowship
program they train you as a student and
uh then you go to the process of uh
publication and Trust in your research
project and everything
so this is my own experience that why I
particularly got interested in find
biotech created fellowship program and
lots of other some other programs that
is because over here you get a hands-on
experience with bioinformatics tools
earlier I had seen other places where
they give you the coursework and then
they teach YouTube tutorials that is how
it's just done but they don't allow you
to perform the exercises by yourself
over here and not only had an experience
of doing and using all the bioinformatic
tools but I also had an exposure to you
know using the tools which were on their
server which is the pipeline and that
was so useful and not only the usage of
pipeline by one click but you even get
to know the code that were implemented
in designing that uh pipeline if anyone
wants to go in that case now what
happens is in wet lab if people have
experience it takes years to get one
result or even if if you want to find
any Gene of your interest it takes years
but if you have an idea from a wet lab
and if you want to see in which
direction it goes bioinformatics is one
of the best tools to you know convert
your wet lab hypothesis into a dry lab
hypothesis and get the results
over here if an undergraduate wants to
start a research in an early career I
would definitely recommend fine
biotech's research fellowship program
because it not only takes you to the
process of research and Hands-On
activity but after you complete your
three months internship I mean a
fellowship program you even take to the
process of crafting your research paper
publication and research students knows
have important stitches for the
publication to go haywired
so it is the interaction from mentors
not only the in-house mentors I got
exposed to but Pine biotech has research
Symposium uh through twice a year or
once a year and then that you get
critical reviews from mentors from all
over the world and some of the leading
universities which tells you where you
stand how much you need to progress and
I think reviews like that you cannot get
on a normal basis like hey I'm emailing
a professor and I want to review on this
no one would ever care to reply to your
email but getting involved in pan
biotech not only helped me to do such
things but also participating in the
research in posture help you to learn
from different mentors all over the
world how they uh progress how they work
and my work also got reviews which I
know okay now I need to focus on this
direction I need to move on this
direction I never knew how to write a
research
paper for this incent but after
completing this research Fellowship when
I started writing on my first paper the
mentors you know really helped me out
about how to bring out the layout of the
paper what points need to be addressed
what point needs to be included so it's
just not only a project where you just
work on a project and leave it they
expect the outcome now the outcome could
be in the terms of posture or resistance
paper
every week when I say you have to
present your progress you just thought
says that a mentor I have done this for
all things you have to prepare a proper
Point presentation and show them okay I
did this thing think that my result and
these are my difficulties by doing so
they also are aiming to improve your
presentation skills which is very much
needed in this world so this were the
key Logistics or the key points I
learned from the research program at uh
Pine bartek and I really think that it
stands out because I don't see any other
institutes or companies giving such many
advantages in one goal
sure it's just a very brief idea about
what my project was I worked on multiple
sclerosis and I wanted to find out the
genes that are involved in the memory
loss multiple sclerosis patient or if
you've seen that are concerned with any
kind of a regulator or unregulated
pathway so first at Pine biotic when you
um enroll for the research fellowship
program actually you have General
coursework and findings like that they
ask you to plan your research proposal
or your hypothesis on which you want to
work for and from there they take it
forward it's definitely like a whole
scientific community and they do
everything a step by and level five it's
nothing haywired so after completing my
uh project uh I presented my posture
with the same project as the fine budget
and research symposium
so there were mentors from all over the
world and not only this but my own
mentors helped me to design you know
help me get through the poster because
this was my very first poster and I had
no experience sharing a postage of the
four so I presented the poster that find
my attitude system for him and I was
very thankful because I won the best
citizen thanks project award so that was
the ability and learning for me but then
I regained my Constitution like no I can
really do this so then I started doing
Hands-On bioinformatics on my own and
trust me now there is no going back
earlier I was so much you know
indecisive of you know who works with
the computers I was running away from
coding I didn't like all these numbers
and stuff and now I'm like there's no
way without bad informatics so after
doing the poster presentation I started
just my first uh you know research draft
so they were not always obviously ones
that had to go through the processes so
I made I mean I wrote my first research
paper and then put it on the preprint
server and after like 9 to 11 months it
got accepted and immunogenetic open
access
a journal so it was uh declared a few
months back so this was about the entire
process regarding how do you go through
the research fellowship program and the
outcome and I would definitely suggest
everyone who is over here to try this
season fellowship program because it
seems that just it's just a research but
when you actually go through it you
cannot even count the number of
advantages it gives you for you know
your future not only this interacted
with many uh mentors who are there in
the Symposium while I was present my
work and I had good opportunity to you
know enroll in future programs and stuff
like that so yeah this was about my
journey